[Music]
filming for season two of the HBO drama
started in March and the cast has been
having a blast working and playing with
newcomer meryl streep she's just amazing
and to watch her do her craft we just go
oh can you believe it we know maro plays
Nicole's mother-in-law who comes to
Monterrey looking for answers after the
death of her son Perry and there is a
report that Alexander Skarsgard who won
an Emmy SAG Award and Golden Globe for
the role may be back for season 2 we're
thinking he'll appear in flashbacks or
possibly a spirit haunting the ladies
interesting interesting things are
happening cuz all he can say now to an
HBO show that has mastered the art of
secrecy for seven seasons Game of
Thrones
to prevent any spoilers leaking for the
eighth and final season cast members
were only given digital scripts that
disappear after they shoot scenes and
they're filming multiple versions of the
ending but here's what we do know when
the final six episodes premiere next
year there will be an epic battle one
that took a record 55 nights to shoot in
below freezing temperatures in Ireland
oh and kit harington's Jon Snow will
finally discover who he really is which
means he's been hooking up with his aunt
and has a claim to the Iron Throne
this season crazy crazy over on the
crown there's a new Queen Elizabeth on
the throne
Olivia Colman replaces Claire Foy as the
monarch for seasons three and four which
will be filmed back-to-back starting
this month producers made the call to
replace the entire cast to better
portray the aging Royals machine
Outlanders tobias menzies steps into the
role of Prince Phillip taking over for
Matt Smith while Helena bonham-carter
replaces Vanessa Kirby as Princess
Margaret and will see her marriage fall
apart season 3 is set from 1964 to 1976
which means we'll be introduced to
Camilla parker-bowles
the current wife of Prince Charles also
expected to return to Netflix in 2019
stranger things I am so excited season 3
is set in the summer of 1985 so that
means there's a year time jump from the
end of season 2 joining the cast Carrie
OS is the mayor Jake Busey the son of
Gary Busey as a reporter and 19 year old
Maya Hawk the daughter of uma Thurman
and Ethan Hawke and we know that Lucas's
sassy little sister Erica will get more
screen time throughout the eight new
episodes and finally it's a showdown for
the Oval Office and the seventh and
final season of veep
the HBO comedy will begin filming next
month after taking a year off while
leaving lady Julia Louie Dreyfus
completed chemo for breast cancer and
her co-stars have rallied around her
she's doing awesome she's getting
stronger and stronger season seven will
pick up with Julia's character Selina
campaigning for president once again
second time's the charm
it's actually a fourth or
[Music]